chez le Président Monsieur les ministres
vous avez choisi le détourner l'objectif
pire peut-être l'esprit du 47,1 de la
Constitution pour museler le Parlement
je n'ai même plus à ce niveau-là de
l'obstruction je qualifierais cela de
piraterie par le mental pour ne pas dire
de déni démocratie le 12 mars à minuit
le couperet va tomber
pour la toute première fois depuis
l'introduction en 96 de ses lois de
financement au sein de notre
Constitution elles sont utilisées pour
mettre en place une réforme de grande
ampleur de notre système de retraite
c'est la première fois en procédant de
la sorte vous portez atteinte à la
crédibilité de notre Parlement
l'équilibre de nos institutions et au
respect de la Constitution ces lois
financières ont pour objet le déterminer
les conditions générales de l'équilibre
financier de la sécurité sociale selon
les termes même de la Constitution et
vous n'ignorez pas que la procédure tout
à fait dérogatoire prévu pour leur
adoption poursuit un seul et unique
objectif
garantir l'entrée en vigueur de la loi
de financement pour l'année à venir
avant le premier jour de l'année civile
concernée
cette procédure n'a jamais eu ne devrait
jamais avoir provocation de permettre
d'introduire insidieusement au terme
d'un examen accéléré tronqué et
parfaitement inadapté aux enjeux de
véritables réformes sociales de fonds
relevant par principe du domaine de la
loi ordinaire par ailleurs en utilisant
cette procédure vous prenez le risque
que le Conseil constitutionnel censure
un minima cela a été dit par notre
collègue assassin les cavaliers sociaux
qu'elle contient car ils n'ont aucun
effet suffisamment direct sur les
recettes ou les dépenses de la sécurité
sociale exemple typique l'index senior
vous faites cela pour deux raisons
simples vous n'avez pas de majorité
maîtrisé au Parlement pour faire cette
réforme premièrement deuxièmement la
seule majorité que vous avez messieurs
les ministres elle est contre vous
contre cette réforme c'est celle des
Français
l’inconstitutionnalité est donc
manifeste pour toutes ces raisons le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain votera la motion présentée
par Madame Assesse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]